do what you love and you'll never work a
day in your life yes have you thought
about what this quote means to you and
your last what decade and a half in LA
do what you love and you'll never have
to go to work or you'll never really
fully work it's mostly true it's mostly
Seville 98% true but you know after you
do a hundred and twenty movies there are
some that there's some days when he does
work but for the most part if you do
what you love you won't have to go to
work why have you chosen acting as a
profession
I didn't choose acting you know it I
think like most actors you won't find
any actors that have a sterling
childhood to talk about I think so you
know mine I was the fat kid the ugly kid
the kid the smart kid with you
know I made straight A's I couldn't
throw a football I had bad acne I knew
all the answers in Sunday school and I
was really huge so um the only the only
way that you can when you're in that
situation you can either fight back or
you can find a way to deflect and so I
just use entertainment for deflection I
think I've never met an actor who I
thought was any good
who said well you know my childhood was
really great you know so um I think just
as a defense mechanism
I chose acting I could also have been a
minister did you ever catch yourself
fighting back and at what point did you
turn it around and say let me use this
as something oh yes absolutely yeah I
remember vividly my acne was so horrible
that I would have a number of kid came
in and said can't you do something about
your face and you know only years and
years later did I think of the snappy
comeback no but I could do something
about yours you know but you never bad
asked when you need it I do remember but
shortly after that that I started doing
imitations of our teachers and
principals and I didn't care if I get
sent to the office as long as the kids
would stop picking on me and they
thought I was cool and so the first time
that they came up to me and didn't shove
me into the locker but instead said
do that imitation - mr. rice you do yeah
do that thing so I was their little
performing monkey but at least they
weren't hitting me so that's been the
whole thing is just the only reason I've
ever done this is to say please don't
hit me but if you entertain people
generally they won't hit you right so
it's good so in 2013 we met you at your
church I think was at first presbyterian
in Hawley you touch absolutely gorgeous
and we've done another interview with
you prior to that and when we turn off
the cameras I think you'd talked about
how maybe you weren't sure about
continuing with acting is this okay to
talk about yeah it is okay to talk okay
because we can stop if you want no no no
no good yeah um so 2013 sue my math is
Right three years okay yeah what are
your thoughts now because we're on a
movie set by the way for the people
watching this in Altadena absolutely
gorgeous place it's that night it's
getting close to 11:30 p.m. and we've
just watched you perform it's a
fascinating scene I won't give too much
away I don't know if it's toward the end
but it's really cool I wish people could
see how neat it was up here and to watch
your performance we just kind of saw it
from the side and you're in a very end
viewable position I was watching them
put this blood on you and it was just
cool but 2013 you said maybe this isn't
for you camera acting is funny because
at some point you have to become a
product or you're not able to succeed
right so in the beginning you - as much
as you can just because you love it and
you want to become established in this
case become established in our life but
at some point if you're going to have
any value to these productions the only
reason they're gonna hire you at above
scale if they're not hiring YouTube of
scale there's no point in it unless
you're rich the only way you're going to
get above scale is to become a product
in a commodity and that's the point at
which
you have to find ways to reignite your
passion because once you become that
commodity you lose a little bit of the
love for the craft and the passion for
the craft it's so easy to let it slip
away and not realize it and the worst
thing is a sense of entitlement when
you're the person that they bring in for
two or three days and then they put your
name above the title are very high up
you're the sizzle and they brought you
in to do the wrap around story or
whatever it is you're adding value to
the project it's so easy to to feel I'm
entitled to that and you're not you're
not you know so you forget how to be a
part of the team and I've been guilty of
that more than once so I have to work on
it
you